poco ambiente en ese estadio de albed
todavía el estadio más lejano que
tenemos en esta copa mundo lo que sí
sabemos es que Inglaterra y senegal ya
saben quién los esperaría en ese cruce
de cuartos de final sería la Francia de
kilian mbappé tenemos ya alineaciones
confirmadas para este partido entre
ingleses y senegaleses con Inglaterra un
cambio en el ataque el ingreso de boca
yo saca el delantero del Arsenal en
reemplazo de Marcus por el delantero del
Manchester United boca estará acompañado
por Harry kane y foden en la delantera
no cuenta para este partido el
seleccionador
Sterling quien aparece ausente en la
lista de convocatorias según reportes
por razones familiares con senegal
también hay cambios o uno obligado en la
medular el de quien acumula
amonestaciones en su lugar entra nanpali
respecto a la victoria contra Ecuador
también hay otro cambio en la modular el
ingreso de diata en lugar de papel
Inglaterra que llega este partido
sabiendo que fueron finalistas en la
pasada Eurocopa semifinalistas en Rusia
2018 se miden Eso sí ante los campeones
de África pero la historia las
estadísticas están de su favor en siete
enfrentamientos previos con selecciones
africanas los inglesas nunca han perdido
Juan y otro tema del mundial han
trascendido novedades sobre el estado de
salud de Neymar
compareció el seleccionador tita en la
rueda de prensa previa al partido de
este lunes y octavos de final contra
Corea del Sur dijo el seleccionador que
confía en que Neymar esté disponible
para este partido para este partido
después de recuperarse de esa elección
en su tobillo derecho que sufrió en el
encuentro inaugural en esa Victoria
contra Serbia dijo tita que iba a
esperar a lo que viera en el
entrenamiento que celebró hasta hace
unas horas Brasil aquí ya en la noche de
Qatar en la víspera de ese partido
contra el combinado asiático afirmó tite
que si Neymar se encuentra bien y lo
pondría de inicialista afirmó que si un
jugador está en buenas condiciones
físicas debe comenzar desde el inicio